[MUSIC PLAYING]
Did you know that Android
has over 70 standard views
built into the operating system?
But no matter how many
standard views there are,
sooner or later, you're
going to want something
that the built-in
components just can't do.
Luckily, Android has great
support for custom views.
It's easy to make a view that
changes built-in behavior
or does something
new altogether.
What can be hard is making
that custom view perform well.
My name is Ian
Ni-Lewis, and I'll
show you how to avoid some
of the performance pitfalls
that come with
making a custom view.
See, the standard views
that come with the framework
have been around a long time.
And the Android
team has had plenty
of opportunities to make
these views better and faster.
When you use those
built-in views,
you get the benefit of all
those years of tuning for free,
but when you create a view that
does its own custom drawing,
you're on your own.
Let me give you an example.
I noticed that some
of my coworkers
are way too productive,
so I'm going
to write them a
game of solitaire
to keep them occupied.
And naturally,
that playing field
is going to be a custom view.
So there's three main
categories of mistake
I could make with this
view, performance wise.
First, I could waste
time drawing things
that haven't changed.
Second, I could waste time
and bandwidth drawing pixels
that will never be visible
because they're covered up
by something else.
And third, I could spend too
long running code in onDraw.
So let's start with drawing
things that haven't changed.
Remember, all drawing starts
with a call to View.invalidate.
The first rule of custom views
is to never call invalidate
when you don't have to.
If nothing in the
view has changed,
then doesn't need to be redrawn.
And the second rule
of custom views
is to always pass a
rectangle to invalidate.
Now, that rectangle is
called the dirty Rect.
It's a hint to the system to
tell it which part of the view
has changed.
So the system uses
that rectangle
to help it decide
when to call onDraw.
For instance, if your dirty
Rect is behind another view,
then there's no point
in redrawing anything.
So being smart about
when and how we
call invalidate means
that onDraw gets
called less frequently.
But sooner or later,
it does get called.
So that's when things
get interesting.
See, the performance
of onDraw is
what determines whether an app
is a fluid, magical experience,
or an irretrievable jank fest.
And the easiest way to destroy
your onDraw performance,
at least on some
devices, is overdraw.
Let me show you what I mean.
You see, check out
these overlapping cards.
You can't see it, but
every card in that view
is being drawn completely,
even the parts that are going
to be hidden by the card above.
And because you can't see
it in the final product,
it's wasted work.
Now, in another video, we talked
about the debug GPU overdraw
feature that's built in into
the Android developer options.
If you turn that on,
almost all of these cards
are going to turn red.
That's thousands
of wasted pixels,
and every single one of
them costs in two ways.
First, when the bitmap
is read from memory.
And second, when the
frame buffer is written.
So how can we get rid
of all that waste?
Well in this example, I know
I've got overlapping views,
so I want to tell
the GPU to only draw
the visible part
of each element.
I can do that by setting
the clip rectangle.
The clip rectangle is the
area of the screen that
is affected by a draw call.
The pixels outside of the
rectangle don't get touched.
They don't cost anything.
The method that lets me do
that is Canvas.clipRect.
When you call this method, the
output of every subsequent draw
call is limited on the
GPU to that rectangle,
and that lasts until the
next call to clipRect.
Now, the performance
gain we see from clipRect
is going to vary some, based
on the GPU you're targeting.
On lower end GPU,
gain is dramatic.
But if you're targeting
higher end GPUs,
you might not see much
benefit at all from clipping.
You know, I tested
my solitaire code
on a Nexus 9, which has got
a relatively powerful GPU.
And I found that I was
actually spending more time
on the CPU calculating
the clipRects than I
saved on the GPU by
eliminating overdraw.
Which brings us to the most
difficult and most important
part of custom views, reducing
the CPU cost on onDraw.
Here's a few tips to
help you with that.
One, don't draw anything
you don't have to.
A clipRect is going to prevent
the GPU from drawing offscreen
pixels, but it can't reduce
the CPU cost of a draw call.
And some drawing calls do
need to use a lot of CPU.
That's especially true when
you're laying out text.
So call Canvas.quickReject
to identify elements that
aren't currently on screen.
If quickReject returns true,
don't draw that element.
And quickReject won't return
true for drawing elements that
are partially unseen,
only for elements
that are completely invisible.
And then hint number two,
don't use draw methods that
aren't hardware accelerated.
Check out this handy guide.
It shows you everything
that's hardware accelerated
and everything that isn't
on each version of Android.
Now, hardware accelerated
means that the drawing
happens on the GPU.
Now, if a method isn't
hardware accelerated,
that means it needs to
use the CPU to draw.
And then it has to send
the results to the GPU
to get composited with
the rest of the view.
Compared to accelerated
drawing, this
is horribly, horribly slow.
So if the method you
want isn't accelerated,
you might want to see if you
could find a different way
to draw your view.
Finally, don't make
allocations in onDraw.
Don't make allocations
in any code
that gets called from onDraw.
Allocations cost two ways.
First, there's
the immediate cost
of allocating and
initializing an object.
And then later, there's the
cost of garbage collection.
Either one of those costs
can be enough to cause
a dropped frame.
Now, a lot of this
advice might seem
like nit-picking over
relatively small perf gains.
But keep in mind when
your view is animating,
onDraw gets called
60 times a second.
And unlike most other code, it
has to run on the UI thread.
So bad performance in onDraw
is going to translate directly
into jank in your app.
You've got 16 milliseconds,
at most, to draw the screen.
Realistically, once
you factor in overhead
from other parts of your app
and potential GCE pauses,
you've probably got half that.
Every millisecond counts.
And if you like counting
milliseconds as much as we do,
you'll definitely want to check
out all the other great info
on the Android Performance
Patterns homepage.
Don't forget to join
our Google+ community.
And remember, keep
calm, profile your code,
and as always, perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]